Pues sí Santiago qué tal la muy buenas
noches Pues en lo que sabemos según el
Centro Nacional de Huracanes es que
efectivamente ese huracán ha tocado
tierra alrededor de las tres de la tarde
en Cayo costan entre las ciudades de
Sarasota y Fort Myers y Está avanzando a
un ritmo muy lento ha dejado una
auténtica destrucción a su paso por lo
que las primeras imágenes que hemos
podido ver de algunas personas afectadas
que han compartido imágenes a través de
las redes sociales sabemos también que
más de un millón 600.000 personas en
todo el estado están sin servicio
eléctrico y las autoridades ya advertían
que esta marejada ciclónica es
catastrófica con Fuertes lluvias y
vientos también hemos podido ver pues
numerosas casas que han quedado bajo el
agua también vehículos porque también
según los meteorólogos y sus pronósticos
decían que se podía aumentar el nivel
del mar hasta tres metros pero es que
viendo las imágenes se puede sospechar
que en la catástrofe Aún es mayor pero
como les digo Aún es muy temprano para
hacer valoraciones básicamente porque
aún el huracán está atravesando Esa esa
parte la zona oeste del estado de
Florida el huracán tiene forma circular
ya ha pasado esta primera parte Esa
primera pared también ese ojo del
huracán cuando se puede asumir una
cierta calma tensa y ahora es Está
avanzando con esa segunda pared de una
forma mucho más violenta Santiago ya
como usted lo dice Anthony ya se habla
de algunos daños ya se puede ver así en
algunas imágenes de gente que postea a
través de las redes sociales que dicen
en cuanto a las autoridades en cuanto a
las ayudas por parte de las autoridades
para ayudar a todos los afectados que
van a quedar a lo largo de la noche
si la Casa Blanca ya informó esta misma
mañana que a través de la agencia
Federal de manejo de emergencias se van
a se habían destinado ya 700 personas
para ayudar a las personas que
necesitaran ayudas a Los afectados por
este huracán también desde el gobierno
de Florida se han desplegado más de
5.000 personas de la guardia nacional
además de otros 2.000 que han venido de
otros estados pero el gobernador de
Florida ya ha advertido que se han
recibido numerosas llamadas de
emergencia sobre todo de personas que a
pesar de que habían recibido
orden obligatoria de evacuación se han
quedado en sus casas y ahora están
pidiendo ayuda el gobernador ha dicho
que se está tomando nota de todas esas
llamadas de ayuda pero los equipos de
emergencia no pueden salir porque sus
vidas correrían